Hi,
eight or implicit.
Okay,
well go
to your mom's house.
Christina
is this guy.
I know who it is.
I got it.
I remembered it.
That's the guy.
I said,
come here.
Tickle your pussy.
I got it.
Yeah.
Thank you.
And he ate out raven.
Simone.
That's so raven.
What a Dick for outing her like that,
you know.
Okay.
I got it.
The line.
Remember,
I don't,
I don't like it.
It's funny.
I don't want to see it on your pussy bitch.
Huh?
That's funny.
Um,
for that.
So he,
it'd be a great shirt,
but he fucking told people what he did with.
Huh?
That's not how you,
that's not,
you shouldn't do that.
No Rolling Gentlemen.
Never told you're not supposed to tell many squeezers in your life and you never
tell me about these bags.
I don't tell anyone.
I don't think.
I don't think that's a cool,
you don't do that either.
He was not cool.
What happens on the road stays on the road.
It's what I'm talking about.
But I'm talking about all of those swinging Dixie,
you played around with any tech.
So many decks.
I'm,
listen,
I'm slow.
I'm dehydrated.
You're victorious though.
I mean,
you,
you did it.
Yeah.
Tell you burnt came in today.
Was it for people that don't know,
we're,
we're recording this on Monday.
I just did Joe Rogan's podcast with my buddy Brent Chrysler,
and we've had this way in this weight loss challenge and today was the way in
and the first of two.
Yeah.
At first it was gonna be a three day way and we just scratched.
That's crazy talk.
So we did two day weigh in.
So we both came in today and he was like,
you know,
I ran like 20 miles yesterday and I did this today.
You know,
he's just being burned like pulsive and crazy.
Right.
And Jane the last,
yeah,
yeah.
Which is exactly how I predicted he would do because we've been thinking about
this as,
and as the weeks have come to a close and yeah,
we were like,
there's,
he's probably Burt's not known for it.
The slow and steady approach.
I played the long game.
He's more of a like,
let's,
let's crunch time,
right?
Yeah.
Let's cram for the exam now.
It's time to do it.
Yeah.
But he looked great for bird look great.
You look amazing.
Wow.
So when he got there,
I was like,
do you think you why?
He's like,
I really think he was weighed myself today because I didn't want to freak myself
out or beat.
So he got there and I was like,
what do you think it is?
He's like,
I think it's at the weight,
the weight.
We were trying to go for it to 27.
Right.
So he goes,
I think I'm up to 27 and I go,
all right.
I looked at him and I was like,
I could see two 25 so I was like,
I think he looks to 25 no.
Explain why to 27 cause that's not just an article right now to 27 was the Bmi
to get you out of obesity in into just overweight.
Yes.
Um,
and we looked it up and 27 that was based on being six one I'm about a half an
inch shorter than Bert.
Technically we would then have different BMI is,
but we both just agreed to do two 27 that was,
now if one of us had stayed over to 27,
that person's still in obesity.
They'd lose the cause.
The whole thing was to try to get out of obesity.
Ari is now part of this and he's,
he was like,
instead of getting the call,
he got the call instead of being congratulating,
he was like,
wait a minute,
wait a minute.
I started to like backpedal about basically not wanting to pay for
Ching on tender hooks.
Here I was in the studio watching you guys on Joe rogan.live.
Yeah.
And I mean,
I heard him,
he,
he picked up,
he's in some other country.
Yeah,
I don't worry.
And he's like,
oh,
I want to see the scale.
And I was like,
back to our height.
We're both well under.
And he was like,
so what I need.
And then he told me,
he was like,
he's like,
you're on the cusp.
You need to not gain any weight.
He told me that today.
Um,
so what,
what happened was Burt weighed in first he was two 21.
I was like gosh,
which is really impressive.
I'm really impressed.
And I knew when I woke up today when I got on the scales first thing and I took
a leak and I got on the skills,
I was two 21 so I was like,
all right,
I know I can,
I can,
cause I went,
I was sweating a little bit,
you know,
doing stuff this morning.
So yeah,
I suspected I would be around two 20 and I ended up being two 19.
Wow.
I was just two pounds,
which is not much but enough to hopefully,
yeah.
So now the thing is,
and by the time this comes out it'll be over this whole thing.
This is like the big election.
Yeah.
This is it man.
This is scary.
The nail biter.
So we are now within a 24 hour window of the way and where we both want to win,
we both need to come in
at or lower than to like basically this is what has to happen.
If we weighed the same tomorrow,
it's over.
I win if I weigh less tomorrow anyway,
I win.
Wow.
If he weighs less,
he has to be more than two pounds less
than me.
So he has to out underway.
You buy two and a half pounds to win tomorrow.
Right.
So your lead theoretically.
Yeah.
So you have to hold that lead.
Wow.
I have full confidence in you.
I,
we know this is teams to girl all the way.
Last night I shaved your back for you.
Um,
a lot of people on Instagram,
they were crediting my back shaving for the weight loss for the weight loss
because that's at least five or 10 ounces.
If you look at the amount of hair in the shower.
Sure.
Um,
do you have a strategy for today?
I think the listeners are wanting to know.
This is my strategy will be,
you know,
uh,
in like I said,
it'll will be after the fact later.
Sure.
We'll know what happened tomorrow.
But,
um,
you know,
I,
I talked to some people and um,
it seems to be the best strategy is to eat some very small,
uh,
meals.
You don't want to completely starve yourself.
Okay.
And would those meals consist of pizza or chicken wings?
It is a,
mostly,
it's actually a chocolate and sausage diet is what it is.
Okay.
Um,
so just a little piece.
So it,
you just have small portions,
uh,
something fatty.
Like I've been having an avocado,
um,
little piece of chicken,
little bit of spinach just to like kind of keeps something in your system.
I'm going to be active,
I'm going to do,
um,
but just cardio.
I'm just some cardio work,
um,
sweat,
you know,
and then I'll do,
I'll do a hot bath tonight.
Get a little more sweat going.
No more fluids down with fluids.
The toughest part is the last couple hours.
Hopefully I'll be,
you know,
I know I'll be fatigued.
I'll be tired tonight.
So you just want to be asleep,
fall asleep.
It's hard,
you know,
getting up in the morning and you want,
you so much.
Want to consume anything,
anything.
Yeah.
So that'll be the hard part.
And then I'll try to get another sweat going,
especially the hour leading up to the way in.
Wow.
So I'll know like when we're done here,
I'm going to go work out,
I'm going to,
you know,
figure out my weight,
I'll figure out how much of that,
and I'll kind of have an idea how much is water weight and I'll know how much I
need to sweat.
I'm really in awe of you.
I mean,
I have to say your discipline,
your,
uh,
your dedication to the game has really been an inspiration to me.
I don't think I've,
I haven't seen you this laser focused and you know,
you're focused about your work,
obviously.
I wouldn't say never,
but I mean,
you've lost so much weight since August,
before this bet by the way.
Like this is something that's been in the works with you for a long time and
like a switch flipped.
And I think you've just been like,
you just been really good genes.
I think we're all proud of you.
Thanks.
Jeans.
I think it's been just like,
you know,
it's the same switch
flip the first time I lost weight,
which was about 16,
17 years ago.
Yeah.
Um,
there's sometimes you just go like,
oh,
I just want to do this.
I don't like being,
you know,
this big and,
you just go,
I'm going to,
I'm just going to do something about it.
You
know,
it's,
and it's 2017 I'm sure like so many people's new year's resolutions,
it's to lose weight.
And ever since I've been doing Paul [inaudible],
he's now,
I do it twice a week.
I've just not long,
it's only been what,
a couple of months that I've been doing this and it really changes.
It changed me already.
Like,
you know,
I feel stronger.
Yeah.
But also like the discipline of just fucking
doing it.
You know what?
Fuck my brain.
Fuck what my mind's telling me.
I just do it and I don't think about it.
And it's so,
it's so gray,
man.
Not so great.
I have the same,
you know,
by the way,
a lot of people have asked,
so I'll just tell them what I did.
Um,
you know,
I got onto a oh,
diet.
The reason I did that is that,
um,
I actually,
I didn't even know.
It's funny that he's my buddy.
I didn't know that,
that Joe had been doing that.
Yeah,
apparently he talks about it.
I had no idea on Instagram.
He's always posting and veggies,
no carb right away.
I actually found out about it from Mike Kennedy,
a different comedian and he sent me a link to it.
And when I was reading it,
I had read about other diets before and you know how people,
obviously you try things and it seemed like I go,
okay,
this seems pretty doable.
And then I actually saw that,
um,
some athletes,
we're proponents of it,
you know,
some,
some like high perform,
like a triathlon people.
And I was like,
oh,
so these are people that you know,
that no nutrition.
Yeah.
And then I saw that,
you know,
some of them hadn't.
Their cholesterol goes down and you get to indulge in like,
I like to indulge as an eater.
You know,
all the good stuff in Quito,
you give up sweetness but you still get to adult yet you know,
sugar.
But you get to indulge in fats.
So,
so you feel fuller actually feel fuller.
And if you're somebody that is like a,
you know,
a Foodie,
you go,
well that's a whole world of deliciousness still,
you know.
So for me it was like I get the satisfaction of eating that fatty food.
It's not like nothing but fat butt,
but it does,
it is,
you know,
a higher fat diet and you know,
you can read all about it and you know,
some people are probably not into it some,
but whatever.
I liked it.
You learn things the whole time.
The big thing,
if you want to make some change to get started,
I would say just cut your sugar once you reduce your sugar,
you know,
it's,
it's a game.
Checks your body burns that sugar off before it will get to the fat.
The reason,
I mean,
there's a lot of other reasons,
but,
but if you're eating a ton of sugar and then that's what your body's going to
burn first.
Yeah.
And you're,
you know,
you get glucose spikes,
you get your body just stores fat.
It's,
um,
he's,
you start gaining weight.
And what Burt said today on on Rogan show,
he's like,
you just can't fucking eat.
And I agree are a big proponent of that.
Just stop fucking eating because the truth is even if you're doing this Kido and
but you're eating a five pound steak.
Yeah,
you can't do that hammer,
you know,
doing all the veggies.
If you're caloric intake is still one thing you're going to be fucking fat
still.
You learn,
you know is um,
portions matter and also Keto teaches you to reduce your protein intake.
A lot of people think that you can just eat as much protein as you want,
but excess protein causes that glucose spike to them.
And so,
you know,
I was somebody that eat enormous
portions are big now.
So basically it's a little bit of protein with some fat to keep you going and
then you get your carbs from vegetables,
veggies.
Yeah.
Great.
No,
no sugar,
no pastries doable.
If I'm telling you I've been doing it,
no fat milk,
if you're going to have actually a little bit of found out I was doing really
heavy.
Creamer is best,
like have you,
and then you dilute that a little bit.
But,
um,
whole milk has sugar in it.
Oh,
right,
right.
I mean,
I was using a splash,
but still the thing is you're learn,
you learn as you with anything.
You're like,
oh,
I was doing that part wrong.
And then you just make your change.
Most importantly,
how have your dump spin on this new diet?
I better.
Much better.
Yeah.
I mean like I'm eating less food and eating a more,
you know,
clean way and I've had very healthy dumps.
That's wonderful.
Because they were very explosive.
Yeah.
And we were,
we were troubled.
Now you gave up sugar,
which for you was,
I mean,
you're the,
you were the guy who we passed by a shop and if there was a chocolate croissant
insight,
it was in your gullet quick.
Yeah.
And that you loved pastries.
That's true.
A lot of them.
So how did you tell me about that process?
I mean,
that,
you know,
the hardest part was the first 72 hours.
Um,
yeah.
I was telling him today that we went to that podcast and you're like,
just don't cause I was snapping at people.
You were out of here with sugar?
With crane.
Yeah.
I know.
I didn't know what was going on.
I mean before I made the decision,
just that like doing it.
So I think it was,
it was more about the choice.
I was like,
I'm just doing this and then just going for it.
It came to the point now that like I don't,
I don't go,
Oh man,
I wish I could have that chocolate croissant and just go like that's not for me.
Cause I think he realized too,
at least what I've,
because I've lost a few pounds to start out with.
Polite but otherwise diary,
proud of your job.
You're a polite,
you've been dedicated.
Yeah.
I've never seen you dedicated to fitness.
Never.
Cause I hate it and I still hate it.
It's not that I enjoy exercising,
it's that I have to,
because I'm 40 years old and this is it for me.
Like I can't do the second half of my life out of shape.
I refuse to hate myself because I don't like my body.
I haven't liked my body since I was 17 years old and I'm sick and tired of it.
All right.
Thank you.
Um,
both the fuck.
I don't even know what the fuck I was gonna say.
I Dunno.
The Oh,
the Diet stuff.
Yeah.
Oh,
there is a point where you start to go is the chocolate croissant is the joy,
the momentary joy of the chocolate croissant going to make me happier in the
long run.
Meaning tomorrow when I step on the scale and I know I fucked myself out of
today's diet,
is that,
is that going to it long term?
Is this really gonna work out for you?
Start to think,
think like that.
You also go,
what?
What are you doing?
If you've had some results?
Yeah.
Then you go,
do I want to fuck these what I've been doing,
I want to go backwards and gain it and then try to go.
I know,
cause you don't,
you don't and it's not worth the temporary.
Yeah.
You ever heard that saying Kate Moss?
She goes,
nothing tastes as good as skinny.
Feels it's true and I've,
I've always remembered that when I'm around like,
should I,
oh,
I want to cheat the galleys pastries lying around this,
this Christmas I maintained,
I didn't lose,
I just stayed the same weight,
which is like a fucking miracle with all the shit we had lying around.
But I would always think Kate Moss,
nothing tastes as good as skinny feels right.
It feels good.
Yeah.
You should be proud.
You know,
you look better so much better and you're looking in the mirror and you're like,
this is way better.
You don't have to flog yourself anymore for being a fat fuck.
You don't have to hate yourself every time you go shopping.
Right.
I heard you guys talking about that today on the show to where Burt was like,
oh,
you don't have a size 40 at the gap or wherever.
Like,
and that's not that big really.
I mean,
no one would really be able to tell.
I'm a bit of a Fashionista.
I like clothes and it's a bummer to me.
It's a bummer to me.
Like when I'm,
um,
when you go into a store,
like I just know,
see a cool shirt doesn't fit,
doesn't fit.
I know you have another size,
bigger size.
We have,
it's the worst.
When I first had Ellis,
I was,
I weighed in at two oh eight when we,
when we went to the hospital to deliver hand.
We're fully pregnant though.
No,
but I'm saying as a woman,
I've never weighed 200 and I know,
yes,
I know that's baby.
Yes,
that's fluid somewhat.
But it's a lot of that is fat.
How much do you,
do you weigh?
Do you know what you weigh right afterwards?
Like when you leave the hospital?
I would say half of that was actual what baby water with hormonal,
they don't weigh on the way out.
So you don't know.
But I know when I got home I was a size 12 and that's the biggest I've ever
known.
What was the next time you weighed yourself?
I didn't,
I didn't look at the scale for months until we moved out of Redondo because I
just knew that to start on that journey would really,
you know,
you gotta be ready to start losing weight before you do that after a baby.
You shouldn't be flogging yourself over your weight after you have a kid.
But I remember being really big for the first time in my life and really not
liking how that felt terrible.
All the shit looks terrible on me.
Everything looks bad.
It sucks,
man.
Terrible.
But you know what I did though is I would buy nice clothes at,
at the appropriate size.
So then you go,
okay,
I'm going to surrender to this.
By the way,
I did that.
You know,
I,
um,
I bought a lot of Nice clothes.
That's enormous.
Right?
You know,
just because I was like,
dude,
I'm not gonna not have clothes and you're not going to flog yourself every day
when you're in the process of,
of getting in shape or losing weight.
Like if that's not worth it either to be like,
fuck,
fuck me,
I'm so ugly.
I'm just going to wear the same thing.
Like,
no,
dude.
You know what I do?
I bought new clothes.
I know you're a smaller size now.
I'm about to have to get the,
uh,
the next size down for the past.
So exciting genes.
Congratulations.
Yeah,
it's good.
Um,
you know,
I definitely,
like I said today,
I'm not trying to be dramatic about it.
I think I just want to live more like this,
you know,
like I don't have a really goal number.
It's not really about the number,
isn't it?
No,
it's not really what looks you get married to the number,
but no,
I just go,
like right now I go,
I could lose another,
you know,
I don't think it's a big deal.
Well,
the number's good because then you can be like,
I got to weigh myself to see how,
because you don't know how fat you're getting.
Yeah.
Unless you have that number number yet.
Fucking,
but I'm saying like,
I go,
I look at the number and I'm like,
all right,
like,
and I see where I'm at,
I see how I feel.
And I go,
well,
you know,
if I lost another,
yeah.
You know,
I don't think losing another 15 is a big deal now for boys.
I feel like men,
you guys,
all you have to do is stop drinking soda.
I know.
Like I lost 20 pounds.
Oh,
women.
Our body holds on to fat.
Yeah.
Because we need it for like getting periods.
Making babies.
The baby baby.
They want our body.
We're mammals.
Shit.
Oh,
I hooked the old board up,
so we have to,
oh,
sweet.
Megan and I have been together for nearly three years.
She's a beautiful girl who I am very much in love with and I have a lot in
common with.
I can't wait to get home and jumping in a pool.
That guys
world champion fighting.
Yeah.
So crazy that he talks like that.
I bet you la native,
that guy
I'm proud to have come out as polyamorous and now I'm excited to share that.
I'm bisexual.
Yeah.
Keep it to yourself.
Ah,
thank God.
All the heads.
Yeah,
I'm proud.
Uh,
now I'm stoked to come out of the [inaudible] crazy man.
So this is kind of big.
I'm going to fluid bond with Jesse.
Yes,
yes.
Oh,
I love it.
Happy.
It's bad.
I'm going to fluid bonded with Jessica.
Jessica,
I'm on the blue and bond boy.
So today Burke,
I'm Rogan was like,
yeah,
I don't know if you noticed,
but when Tom and Kristin near the,
they're like the biggest assholes everywhere.
I know.
I felt bad.
I was like,
you got home.
And I'm like,
oh my God,
I hope I wasn't too mean to Bert.
I mean I w you know,
we're just talking shit and I do.
God bless Sam.
I do is really be serious.
And yeah,
I know.
Hurt him and love him.
So of course everyone loves Burt and I texted them both Burnley on.
They haven't responded yet,
so no,
you hurt their feelings.
That's what the,
I had the bubble NAM case.
I went inside the land of the man wants to go inside.
If he can win.
Couldn't do it man.
But I did.
I said I could do it and I can
imagine that as the glitz man.
Oh,
he's tacking,
he might be mentally ill a little.
I had a window.
I don't know.
That was kind of manic,
wasn't it?
I'm on the fence.
Yeah.
It seems a little manic to me a little bit.
It's like this
don't drugs.
Yeah.
Flip it comes on your legs this way.
Go and they
really
poor raven.
It's let's just like you like,
yeah.
You like I said Hey.
Yeah.
What does he do for a living?
I think he does music now.
He was an actor.
Maybe.
I don't know that.
It's so tacky to share.
Yeah.
You shouldn't share.
No.
Okay.
You're lucky she lets you eat her pussy.
You dumb.
Fuck.
Yeah.
Right?
You don't talk.
Don't brag about that shit.
God Damn,
that's not cool.
Tacky.
There is.
Um,
whereas this cheat sheet,
there's this thing I've been wanting to show you.
I didn't realize this was the,
it's so fucking great.
So,
you know,
we've been talking about my dad and then other people.
Do Dad accents foreigners?
Yes.
So,
and basically what we're talking about is like when my dad is around,
my mother talks normal,
but when her family comes from Peru,
he adopts a English,
but he has a little bit of a Spanish accent and people have written in with
stories about it.
Absolutely is my favorite thing.
So like you know,
someone wrote in that their dad works or go,
they go to an Asian restaurant and he starts talking to the waitress.
I'm in English but like it with an Asian downtime and some berries.
It's so embarrassing.
So apparently this is what this is here.
Okay.
Joey Barton is an Irish soccer player who played a season for a French team and
he developed the Dad Accent Syndrome during a press conference and then the
sports talk show back at home,
can't wait to ask him about it.
So they recognized that he was doing that.
Um,
and this is just fucking amazing.
Yes.
You mentioned that last there.
How's your French got any better?
Yeah,
a little bit.
Lvst without,
you've got to policy.
Yeah.
So they're setting them up and that's how he talks,
obviously.
Right.
Because you can hear his,
um,
his,
his notable Irish accent.
Yes.
And then this is him doing a press conference with the French Press.
Lindsay Lohan.
Well,
in France,
uh,
speak about this.
It's,
it's,
it's normal in England and,
um,
maybe it takes me one or two game to adapt or it's not a problem.
The one criticism of the French league is it's,
it's a little bit,
uh,
you know,
they,
and I can understand,
you know,
I watch a Neil yesterday,
they have 10 men and they're happy to lose one nil.
Uh,
you know,
they,
they have 10 men and for me you might as well,
five nil is one nil.
That's how he taught,
right?
Yeah.
And he's like,
yeah,
he sounds like a Gallagher brother.
Perfect.
[inaudible] you could get you a job on a lower low.
Gotcha.
Okay.
What's her Louella happened?
Oh,
no.
Clearly what you're trying to do is you're trying to speak in a pattern that the
the European,
the front of Janis Lansdowne,
I get that.
But we will make some stairs.
Yeah.
I'm embarrassed.
Embarrassed.
I oversee and man,
I'm doing a conference.
So it's full of French journalists.
No,
no foreign journalists really in the room and off seat.
And I can not blow for him.
And a really good parliament.
Taxi was sitting in the,
in the bar and I'm talking away and I'd said before the went there,
cause I remember Steve McClaren's famous one nice to rib Steve about was
anything like it.
So I was talking about not doing that when it went out in my mind not to do it.
So anyway,
I'm doing this conference and I see two ads in the bucket
and it just dawned on me that my worst nightmare mostly doing this ridiculous
Fran Jackson.
I've done that.
Yeah.
Thing where I've thought about something I don't like in my act.
Yeah,
no,
don't do that.
And then I'll do it immediately.
Do it.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
So then I'll stop like playing on it to try and get,
I mean,
both of them would in floods of tears and end the often to Warhol at the
conference have gone and the French were just stone syslog and bow hunting.
He did not have any idea what was going on.
Even afterwards when it broke,
it went viral and everyone was actually giving me a,
a bit of a Mickey taken rightly so.
Um,
the French wine,
what
we understood you needed to speak slowly and I was like,
yeah,
Wayne,
just dad.
It is yourself when you make yourself look bigger.
Big Idiot like that.
It's also,
he's a good,
it's good.
It's good in a sense of humor.
She really is cool as shit,
by the way.
I really liked the student.
Yeah,
but why don't you fucking suck?
Oh God,
I wish I could suck it.
Uh,
what's her name?
Did that Lindsay Lohan?
Yes.
She remember,
that's the first instance that we saw where she was like,
and uh,
it's a wonderful thing and this country is like,
what
my dad goes,
uh,
we teach you a,
you enjoy yourself today is nice.
No.
All the people there and then was like,
ah,
yes.
It deal.
Tony's very nice.
Is that the people doing the yes.
Uh,
uh,
and I,
we,
we go many times we've met Betty
joy.
They actually,
I think he's right.
This guy that like,
they think you're just kind of slowing it down.
Yeah.
They don't realize what you're doing either.
No,
I think my dad does that to Spanish speakers too.
He does.
Yeah.
A little bit.
I'd love to do a road trip with your dad.
Go for it to see how he manages things,
you know.
Yup.
You can him.
Um,
I love how European dudes sit with their legs crossed.
I forgot that I cross him sometimes.
My Dad does too.
I feel like,
no,
you don't.
Not like that guy had it.
No,
I usually do the,
the the big fold.
Yeah.
But there's sometimes you're just like,
I dunno,
just depends on,
it's like the seating dictates it.
I had a full lady lady cross.
Yeah.
Europeans do that.
They're smaller.
Right?
We're so fat.
Right.
Americans are too fat to do the The lady cross you can't do late across big old
fat fucks
come to America.
And the,
yes.
Yes.
And uh,
so when did you have a good time?
When I'm least at the thing today.
We had such a good time with them.
I miss them.
That was fun,
man.
I talked to top talk today.
He's on the weight loss.
Kicked to AC.
Now you guys had a little thing going.
We have a bet,
right?
Yeah.
Well what is it?
He has to get down to a certain way.
He weighs less than me.
He's just for reference.
But um,
he does.
Oh yeah.
See,
it's so funny.
I don't,
I can't tell,
I mean right now he might be a little more than me,
but his baseline weight is way less than my baseline.
Interesting.
So,
um,
anyways,
if,
uh,
if he gets to the goal weight,
I have to go with him on a fucking cruise,
a four day cruise,
worst I hate Cruz is way worse.
Or is it the cruise or the four dayness of it.
God dammit now and on one hand a four day cruise,
you're in,
you're out.
I don't want,
I fucking hate cruises,
but I also want them to get through a full choir.
So anyways,
if I win,
if you don't,
we're not when,
but if he doesn't,
we have to do a trip that I want to do.
So I just tried to make it something that he doesn't want to do.
Vietnam
couldn't do that to him.
He wouldn't even take that seriously.
I said Brazil,
which I would love to go,
I'm dying to go to,
but he said he was like,
he's like,
I don't want to go to Brazil.
And I was like,
exactly.
It's hot.
It's muggy.
Actually,
if he does it,
who is spicy,
I think I'll just let them,
I'll let them go somewhere else.
But like I tell him that he hears the beauty of your father is that no matter
where you take him,
all he's going to want to do is sit in the hotel room and watch Turner classic
movies.
That's all he wants to do.
So why even make him travel?
Doesn't matter where you go.
The only place he wants to go abroad is England has never been.
And I think even then he would be like,
oh,
this is going to see this thing.
And we'd go see fucking big Ben or something and then gonna go back to the room
buddy.
And He'd be like,
oh,
I mean we just got out here.
So I
do want to go,
you know,
whatever Buckingham.
Yeah,
it big.
This is big.
Ready again when I get something to eat.
The thing is,
I think he thinks England is just America with funny accents.
They might,
I think he does.
I don't think he understands that it's Europe.
It's not that the doorways are narrower,
everything's small.
He's reached such an incredible level of repeating himself.
Like he was telling me that his brother lost a bunch of weight.
Right.
Which one?
Steve [inaudible] the one that's alive rock by and then the,
um,
the one that's alive.
Yeah.
I'm sorry.
I thought he had more than no too,
for some reason though.
So,
okay.
He goes,
I'm Steve lost a bunch of weight.
I go,
that's great man.
We'll see.
Wasn't ever that big.
And I go,
how'd you do that?
And he's like,
you know,
anything is,
he did it the old fashioned way,
you know,
count calories and uh,
just kinda did it like that.
And I go,
Yup.
Since he told me that story,
he has told me that story 10 more times and every time he says it,
I know you already told me this.
I know.
I just,
I like to repeat myself.
He just does that.
He learned,
he owns that.
He just likes to repeat himself.
Same thing with the retirement on the horizon because,
and I can retire.
It's a,
you know,
just holding mentality,
getting ready for a retirement and uh,
you know,
we all the whole different thing,
it's just the next chapter.
I'm like,
Yup,
I indulge it the first couple times like oh yeah,
and the next 25 times I talked to him,
you know,
retirement and we had a mentality like that.
I know you've already fucking said this.
It's so funny.
Yeah.
You know,
it's cute.
He goes,
I got my calorie counting book.
It tells you how many calories,
which is funny cause there's like,
there's a calorie counting book on this thing called the road back to you.
Who Was it?
No,
it's a calendar reminder.
Oh,
I'm thirsty.
I know.
I'm sorry.
Sorry.
Can you drink a little or no,
I'm just going to,
there's a sip.
I'm just going to cut.
Are you being serious?
Yeah.
You're not gonna drink it all on his whole tomorrow.
Not until 1130.
I is that safe?
Probably not.
Because you drank a little.
Please write on the way out of here.
Oh,
right.
Yeah.
Just have a sip of my water.
Seriously.
You want it right now?
Okay.
You want to have an orange?
Oh God.
Oh yeah.
Um,
so a bunch of people have sent in a mommy and jeans.
So excited about this movement.
I really am.
I think of all the things we've done,
this is definitely one of my favorites.
Yeah.
Let me see.
Is this,
do you want to play what we've been working on?
Sure.
How that's influenced?
Uh,
America really,
when you think about it,
let me see.
Yeah,
this is,
uh,
this is you here.
Oh,
you want to start with mine?
Okay.
No thanks.
I'm just glassing.
All right.
What can I get credit for you,
mommy?
I'd like a double tall ice,
uh,
soy latte and a bottle of water.
That's it.
Thank you.
Thanks jeans.
That's great.
No,
I also ordered a bottle of water.
I don't think you do that,
but just checking.
Oh my God.
So I don't know.
I don't know if you noticed,
but I incorporated Jess glass
is another level.
I think we should start adding more and more.
I think also it should be how you negate any suggestion or there was no you
like,
oh,
can I get you something to eat?
Just glasses.
Glasses.
Yeah.
What can I get you right,
right.
Uh,
I think we always have to go there.
Would you like to try the number two?
Right,
so special and you go up.
No,
I'm just glassing no,
now and I think there should be,
if you can add more your mom's house sayings,
the better the order.
Yeah.
So let's,
let's stop this game up a notch.
Well,
here's what I did.
I get something certainly paid here.
This is a different night.
So I had already ordered,
I call them jeans again.
Took a while for him to,
I posted the front half of this on Instagram.
Yeah.
Nice guy.
Always.
Yeah,
they did.
They do their thing and stuff like that.
They're good
man.
This is this.
As long as it's taken to get,
I know,
but whatever,
it's a drive through the drive through.
You're not even getting out of your car.
Got Him on in there.
I love you
man.
You got an I love you.
So now the game is,
is elevated.
We've got just glasses and if you can tell somebody you love them.
Beautiful.
Okay.
Thanks ma'am.
I snuck it in.
I love you right.
If you can get in and I love you a hey Hitler.
Just glassine kiss my policy's a little much
mommy.
Um,
okay.
I'm ready.
Can we get it?
Number five,
mommy,
mommy and large west.
Drink
a medium.
Sorry.
What to drink
power.
You please.
What flavor of Howard Howard it is drive through Wendy's.
Oh,
that'll be it.
You're telling me seven 92 already.
Thank you mommy.
Please see that's the best part of doing this.
I don't think you get it if you haven't done it yet.
The best part is the sense of accomplishment after having done it nonsense of
yeah.
It's like you got away with it.
Something so good.
Hi Mommy.
Can I get real clear sized Americano with neck,
wrist shot,
real clear.
Um,
can,
can I be hot please?
Yeah.
And then a regular size.
Hot Americano with hazelnut please.
Uh,
no,
I'm blasting.
Thanks.
Yes.
Great job.
Taken off already.
See?
Yeah.
Wow.
Good word.
That was really great then.
Oh my God,
you sent me this.
Um,
somebody recorded themselves.
Yeah.
Maybe we don't have it queued up already or is it recorded themselves?
It's on youtube.
If you want to go watch.
He called customers jeans for a couple days.
Yeah.
Working behind the counter at what looks like,
like a convenience store.
Yeah.
Um,
he just dictates that the son himself as this hilarious.
So he has a
spot on jeans.
Can you smokes smokes.
This is called the Osprey mom
jeans.
Fantastic.
Hey Buddy.
The smiles at the camera work exemplary.
Yeah.
Good job for you mom.
Thanks
James.
Awesome.
Yeah,
there's 20 to 60 to
get to work.
Such good work.
Yeah,
I like that he put his job on the line.
Yeah.
I mean please smart and record himself only.
Yeah,
that record.
Yeah.
People walk in,
they can't see that he's doing it.
They don't know what the hell he's saying.
It's so good.
Not even once.
At least on camera.
Have we heard anybody be like,
what'd you call me?
Or what'd you say?
No,
it's best part.
He's so pleased with themselves.
Another day.
Hold on,
James Exemplary work
else.
Jeans.
I'm fine with it now.
Yeah,
he's relaxed.
Him Good at 10 59 you're relaxed into the shit.
Yeah,
he's owning it.
How's
your mom?
His handle is marched Melo,
m a.
S,
h,
e d mellow regular Amazon.
It's called,
I called the customers' jeans a couple of days.
Killing us by James.
Brilliant.
Yeah.
I have to say this really
takes a whole hi mommy thinks genes game up a notch because not only this guy
put his employment on the online.
Yeah.
You don't have to do that for your mom's house.
No.
Um,
but no,
you're right.
Nobody would actually,
I mean,
it was it on the line.
Like what,
what,
what's the,
what's the worst?
Someone can say,
what'd you call me?
Oh,
jeans.
It's like a,
you know,
it's like,
dude,
no,
someone,
cause his boss could see this video.
I don't want him to get in trouble,
but uh,
really stepping it up a notch.
It's really good.
Really exemplary work guys.
Wow.
I'm really impressed.
Really,
really,
really impressed.
Thanks gene.
Thanks jeans.
Um,
we were sent it.
I think you can guess so silly.
Why don't I start with
my love for dance?
Obviously a fan.
Yeah.
Obviously listener.
I don't know.
I start with my love for denim.
I know,
you know,
I think about denim from the past.
From the past.
Yeah.
That's a lot of denim.
That much denim is out there.
He loved jeans.
Yeah.
You know,
and then I think about like two of the designers back then.
Now we're making durable denim,
you know,
for those guys to the minors.
There you go.
So good.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
The new genes genes became the official thing of California or some really,
Durable Denim.
Good stuff,
man.
Yeah.
Someone sent us an article about how genes have become the official California
fabric or something like that.
Yeah.
I don't know.
Let me look it up.
That's what this is for.
[inaudible]
this is,
what are you going to eat tomorrow?
Let's talk about that.
Oh,
well,
I don't know if we mentioned it last week.
We have a waffle date.
I haven't had a waffle in fucking forever or does the only tree that I've
actually been like,
oh,
I'll try that again.
So we're going to a special waffle place.
We looked it up.
Yup.
I mean,
I'm very excited.
Yeah.
I used to go there as a kid and it changed owners.
Anyway,
Governor Jerry Brown just signed the bill.
Naming Denim,
the official fabric of California.
Hmm.
Pretty Cool,
Huh?
Yeah,
there you go.
It's fitting.
It's fitting given the state as the birthplace of Levi Strauss,
the company first pass at posited,
it's iconic blue denim jeans in San Francisco back in 1873.
Wow.
There you go.
That's true.
There's the factory in a man friend disco.
Wow.
Well,
the fabric of Denim is widely believed to have been invented in many hundreds of
years ago.
Yeah,
there you go.
Yeah.
All right.
Thank you,
Governor Jerry Brown and Brown.
You know what that sound means,
right?
Oh,
dates.
Yeah,
go for it.
You want to do it?
I don't have mine up.
Okay.
Uh,
I'm going to be in Kansas City,
Kansas.
Shitty,
Kansas,
shitty at the Improv five shows.
They're moving.
So if you're in the area,
get your tickets.
They're glass in glass and hard.
Um,
and I'm already 12.
Let's start there.
Oh,
go ahead.
No,
February 12th.
We're doing the podcast five,
by the way.
The tickets are moving.
Fantastic.
We're doing at the Irvine Improv,
which is a big room.
It'd be the biggest audience we've ever had for a live podcast.
It's Sunday,
February 12th,
I believe it's 7:00 PM.
Go both to Tom cigarette.com or a thousand ranch.com.
Get those tickets.
I'm in Oxnard,
also known as Cox,
hard to California next week at levity live five shows there.
Then my big tour starts it.
I've been talking about forever and I'm really excited about it.
New Orleans,
Atlanta,
clear farter Jew Harlene Tallahassee.
That's my first weekend.
Um,
I haven't gotten updates on the,
uh,
new horror jeans and I'm clear fighter,
but I know it's,
it's close.
I know Atlanta sold out.
So scoop up tickets if you want to,
Tom,
cigarette.com.
I'm excited.
There's a bunch of dates coming up.
Please look them up.
Jeans,
an addition to February 12th at the Irvine Improv with my jeans.
Uh,
May 4th and fifth fart.
Nick's Arizona at stand up live.
May 19th through 20th June Dork titties at Gotham comedy club.
I'm super stoked to be doing it.
I have never done New York shitty except for Brooklyn in Brooklyn,
but I can't really,
you haven't done your thing dude.
I'm so,
I'm glad.
The first one,
May 4th through fifth and Fart next Arizona,
another great standup ride.
Yeah,
that's great mode.
And then June 16th or 17th,
man friend disco at the punchline comedy club.
Come on your club.
Love it so far.
This is great.
This is just the beginning of 2017.
We'll see what goes down.
You know what I'm saying?
Filament.
Oh.
Also check out that Steve Rowe,
if you haven't already.
I just talk some fucking shit to get fucking weird.
Talk about life getting your entire life,
stuff like that.
You know what I'm saying?
I got the update today that Washington Dick come.
Um,
my improv Friday and Saturday are sold out.
So I still have some Thursday tickets.
Washington deck comes.
Fantastic.
I'd had the best time there.
You're,
you're gonna like the way you look.
I guarantee it.
I love you Tom.
I love you too.
Happy a junior pepe juniors happy new juniors to yeah,
happy new juniors to you too,
man.
You were gone.
I didn't get to kiss you.
I know you were in horror.
Lando.
I was actually doing so I was doing this so I'm about to show you.
Oh,
who's doing this?
Well,
I was in Orlando.
Boy wouldn't be talking about
what a piece of shit you are
and this guy is an incredible piece of shit.
God is activations.
You know we've talked about this before and that is that every guy finds a lane
to get laid.
Absolutely magical imperative that you think are not out to get laid.
Yeah.
Are just deceiving you.
In how and what their lane is.
That's their racket.
They're like,
I'm,
the guy doesn't want to get laid.
And that's how I get like this fucking scumbag.
I mean,
describes this guy.
He is a,
it looks like he's of Indian descent.
What kind?
I don't know.
Let's just say from that world.
Um,
he's got the gold arm band.
He's shirtless,
he's got gold arm bands,
a big gold chain.
Looks like my mother would wear that necklace.
I know where the F that's from.
Fricking H and.
M Dude.
He ain't no real Indian.
Well you have that necklace.
That's what I said.
My mother would wear it.
It's a five 99.
I just meant that it's a pos from H.
And.
M I have the same lines as a ridiculous belt on.
He's got a,
he's got a a line painted on his head,
so he's like,
no,
this is uh,
you know,
I'm,
this is my ancient teachings.
Hindu Visha sure.
This,
my grandfather taught me this and this means that my chairs are from,
I come,
doesn't dry quickly.
I think this line on my forehead doesn't dry quickly.
Yeah.
It's all like nonsense.
So he's made this video about threesomes.
At least two women are lying on the floor.
He's standing,
he's squatted over the middle of their hands,
looks like their hands are on his junk and they're lying.
They're like,
oh,
teach.
Teach us as well.
You know,
like they need to be schooled.
Yeah.
The twin goddess activations.
Yeah,
please.
Your hands are on their toes,
so he has one hand on either in the middle of the tits.
Both girls.
Right.
It's activation for the twin goddess.
Yeah.
Warming up the entire body.
Anyway,
the titles,
it's just like the gays.
Yeah.
Yay.
Massaging the tips.
He's rubbing their tests now.
Bullshit.
Oh,
hey,
grace her titties.
So yeah,
he's great course.
Of course.
Only when the whole body is warmed up.
Do you connect with the Yani Yoni,
and I'm able to
such a
ball center course.
This motherfucker's not even like from India.
You know what I mean?
Like maybe his great,
great grandparents came over when this camera goes off.
He's like,
look,
I'm just trying to fuck.
Yeah,
that's exactly what happens.
Fuck
your h and m necklace.
Now he's on the Yummy.
Oh,
shut up.
The Nickelodeon
grabbed their pussies.
Here's the other thing that's crazy about this.
This under the guise of I'm teaching,
I'm making an instructor gets you all these fields.
In other words,
they're like,
we're helping,
right?
So like,
yeah,
I'm just,
I'm doing the trying to teach right now.
Another thing,
you know,
I don't know why there's this assumption that all female sexuality is identical.
Like,
you know,
women,
you guys are all about your feelings for,
and like,
I know a lot of women who are hardcore horse thugs bitches who don't give a fuck
about feelings.
I know girls who fuck harder than dudes that,
you know what I'm saying?
Like their numbers are crazier than,
dude,
this is bullshit.
Like,
come on now.
Really?
You're trying to tell me this guy,
he got to rub around her.
You know how aggravating that is to a woman,
by the way,
when a,
when a fucking dude rubs around your pussy like,
no dude,
get in there bro.
Listen to you.
I speak for a fucking,
you know how many days like this I'm banging his hands as opposed to hand.
It's frustrating when guys do all this.
Oh,
I have to be extra special because no,
you don't just fucking touch it.
Bitch
tells me,
Oh no,
I'm at the gate of your temple.
No Shit.
Dummy.
Yeah.
Okay.
Then what?
You'll love this part,
they have
to squeeze the Pec muscles.
Oh God.
Have you actually being invited in?
Okay.
And as all of you will have some food,
the certain areas of potential at the cheese ball,
peaceful,
the casebook
presence,
loving and one person's a painting at Hillcrest south reading yet and then the,
the emotions accelerate and it is quite a beautiful,
amazing activation.
Oh my God,
no activation was the word of the day on sesame street.
That's what this reminded me of when he said Shit activator
activator,
this guy.
And I got to tell you that to his credit,
if he didn't have on his h and m necklace and his ridiculous belt,
he's just some fucking mediocre looking guy with a button on his head who would
never be able to get the twin goddess activation.
So you know what?
He's figured shit out on him.
I just feel like definitely a book,
you know,
Bullshit.
Did God bless as they say,
sign off the good.
Good job,
sir.
What kind of check is,
I'm drawn to the the button guy would.
Yeah.
And that too,
because I liked her goddess,
all that stuff.
You know me like I like,
I like spiritual.
No,
and that's a thing,
but my bullshit radar goes,
no.
Now my bullshit detector knows that this guy's full of it.
No,
I know.
It's not real.
Ladies.
Listen,
couple of chicks shoot him down like that and then a couple are like this and
then all of a sudden,
I bet you if you ask them,
how many threesomes have you had is he's like,
I don't know,
500 he what he does,
he goes,
he's self help groups.
He goes to meeting groups and like energy goes after people seeking it,
which is smart.
Yeah.
He's like,
oh his lane,
he's a predator.
He's like a Hyena.
He waits for the prey to be hurt and then he swoops in and it's under a jack all
veil of,
I'm not hunting,
you know,
but that's how he hunts different.
Brilliant.
This guy is,
I just hit stop.
Put your hand back on my day.
There you go.
Consent,
consent guys.
Fucking scumbag.
Big piece of shit.
That guy is asked him,
will you ever date her mom?
I asked him,
I asked him K in that.
I still love that one.
So much.
So do I.
And I don't feel like it got the traction it deserved.
And I think people didn't want to get into that one as much as we did.
No,
I know.
Awesome.
Would you ever marry your mom was like,
Oh really?
Would I really?
Well I had another thought about that.
Boy,
he calls me mom.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
This fucking guy.
That's a thing that girls don't realize.
Oh,
I was going to say that.
Uh Oh.
You know what it is.
I think women,
a lot of the time they make a mistake with dudes is cause they want dudes to act
like women.
You know what I'm saying?
So they think like this fucking asshole,
this pony tail and his h and m necklace like,
oh,
he's sensitive.
He's like a check,
right?
He's got a penis.
Like no bro.
Oh,
thank you for bring that.
Like that's why you got to go for like a dude.
Because if fucking dude is straight forward,
you know what I'm saying?
Like you want to do that.
Let you know what he wants.
Well that too.
And look,
you're never going to find a girlfriend in your boyfriend.
Stop fucking making.
Stop trying to make your boy,
your husband.
Your girlfriend is never going to fucking happen.
And that's why you have girlfriends.
Right.
And You keep the husband out of it.
He let him be a dude.
Right.
Otherwise you get stuck with that fucking bullshitter.
Yeah.
And he's finger banging every other girl in the neighborhood,
twin goddess activating.
It's all love.
That's all.
I'm just,
I'm spreading my Yoni.
Yeah,
it looks really good.
I was going to say that last week response,
a lot of people are into it.
People encouraging you to give it a shot.
Yeah.
I received a lot of artwork.
Photoshop.
Any thoughts on whether or not there's a chance that this could be on a special
artwork?
Right?
Maybe I'm not,
I'm not ruling it out.
Would you marry your mom?
All right.
What's the title of the special though?
Well,
I saw him when somebody made one that was like all caution tape and well that
goes without saying.
I'm going to have my fire,
my flame tee shirt and then caution tape maybe over my mouth.
No,
I know.
You don't know what's going to happen.
Yeah.
Wow.
But what is this,
what is the title of this hour though?
Um,
no bangs allowed.
That was pretty good.
Or no hair?
No fear
about.
I'm halfway there.
Halfway there.
Oh,
I like that one.
But I want it to signify danger.
Oh.
You know,
like
trouble.
Like you know,
like,
oh,
you know what's another good one too?
When the microphone is like a gun or something like Dang,
you know,
tough.
Oh No.
Or maybe and maybe the,
that one,
the funny stuff happens the shoulders and you go,
I don't punish.
It just happens.
Yeah.
That's kind of an interesting one too.
About like cease fire,
cease fire.
These,
my jokes are the bomb.
Something like that.
It was cool.
Well thanks for bringing this back.
Good.
So you like it.
Oh,
I love it.
It's a really cool way that you flattering photo.
Well,
you know what I would have liked in the Photoshop though.
Now I guess he did it right because it's not,
it wouldn't be a gradual fade.
Yeah,
it would just be that harsh.
The Benjamin Franklin.
That's Avastin does look good though.
Yeah.
No,
no,
no doubt.
Do you think that guy would twain goddess activate me if I had that haircut?
Nope.
He wouldn't
even lay me that guy.
It'd be like,
you need to grow that hair back.
Yeah.
That guy on camera.
Absolutely.
Layer off camera.
He'd be like a peg.
No.
He'd be like,
something's wrong with John.
Soccer's would do me.
Yes.
If you told him you were Vegan,
you would definitely do it.
My vegan vagina.
What?
By marrying your mom.
This lady came back.
Uh,
you know about this lady?
Yeah.
The jingle bells.
What is happening?
Oh,
I've got to Fart.
I heard it.
Did it.
Did it register.
It's going to happen.
We've been missing so many parts.
You got really upset about that.
Guess what?
We have a gift for you
and the dog
heard you and your request for a Tom gets mad.
Okay.
Montana.
He built one.
It might be right,
but I don't think so.
God dammit.
You know it's fun now
when the myriad of technology fails.
Hold on a second.
Okay,
hold on.
I'm sweating.
Getting mad.
Good.
Trying to see where the hell is this.
That's good
fucking thing.
What's wrong baby?
Let's talk about
what's that?
There you go.
There's that again.
Pop back in again and I'm really going to lose my mind.
You talk about these constantly.
I was in the airport.
Obviously it's subjective,
but I think it,
you know
to like,
why did that happen right there?
Why did that just depends on what if you're talking about
great job.
There you go.
Very exciting.
Yeah,
very exciting.
You could do it.
We could probably build one of 'em over of just,
God dammit.
I was thinking of that.
Yeah.
That's usually my go to upset expression.
God dammit.
Let's keep archiving these.
Thank you blue band.
Let's keep a thorough record of every time he freaks out because I feel like we
haven't even more anger ones and that.
Yeah,
there's,
there's more time.
A wonderful start.
Thank you.
Really good work.
Just glass.
And how are we doing on those shirts?
Are they still around?
What's the deal?
I set up the thing.
Yes.
So I'm so glad you just reminded me a bad glass.
And is the email that glass and@gmail.com if you go and you send an email to bad
glassine and there's no g and glassine,
right,
bad glass.
and@gmail.com,
uh,
I set up the email address,
you send your um,
proof of purchase,
like your email receipt from your purchase of the just glass and shirt.
And if you got one of the first batch,
which were Gildan,
I'll send you a little something that's very nice cause I didn't know that they
were going to be like that.
So I'm sorry.
Well sometimes when you're just glass and you learn things,
yeah.
If you got the second wave,
you know you've got the right shirt.
So he got the glass,
you can see your tag.
Is this a Gildan?
Are you upset about it?
You can email me just glass and at g mail
items.
I want it to bring up,
yeah,
please go ahead.
That wonderful clip we had last week of the super,
uh,
that guy cleaning out that toilet.
Remember the guy with one tooth and he was cleaning out that vile toilet with
all this shit with no gloves.
Oh my God,
I remember that.
Yeah,
so we started watching that.
it's called the super,
and it's called that because it's super depressing that shows,
it's a fucking bummer,
man,
but really entertaining,
really entertaining.
It's about these poor people who live in,
basically,
it's basically about a slumlord.
Well,
you know,
they're slumps and not slums.
They're pretty bad there.
They all got bed bugs and well,
that's because of the people in it.
I disgusting animals.
And the one that we saw were horrific.
Lord.
These poor people in a lot of them have,
you know,
alcohol and drug abuse stuff happening too.
I watched another episode,
remember that the woman that was living on a piece of Shit,
God,
and he wouldn't show up for the court date and he was out drinking and like,
what are you doing?
Get your life together.
When he got racist,
did he?
Oh yeah,
to the Asian Lady.
You like,
now you're kind,
you're good for an Asian or whatever.
Yeah.
Or then he was like,
oh,
that's the white guy.
I mean,
everything was raised to that counts.
Right?
Yeah.
It was super funny guy.
We actually know the guy that cocreated though show.
Oh,
that's right.
Yeah.
That's so funny.
Um,
we gotta text her about that.
Yeah,
let me wash them.
yeah,
yeah.
Uh,
so we watched that.
That was cool.
And then,
oh,
we went to go feed the ducks yesterday with our son.
Yeah.
Shit.
Now I grew up going to this duck pond and back in the day in the 80s,
you could just bring your loaf of bread and throw it at the ducks and it's like
the best day ever.
So we took our little boy there yesterday and I brought a loaf of leftover
German Rye bread,
a loaf,
because I had,
I'm not eating that shit.
Yeah.
My Dad ate a couple of pieces when he was here and,
um,
we go to the ducks and it was so fun.
I mean,
we've had them,
we threw 'em,
he's the bread up in the air and then the birds would fly by and snatch it out
of the air.
Oh,
was red.
They went crazy.
And then joggers were running like,
excuse me,
walking by kind of Shitty.
And we're there with our boy.
He's just like watching.
And then we get to the other side of that lake on and it says do not feed the
birds.
Lecia I felt like such a pos and it's like,
it messes with the ecosystem.
The birds won't migrate this and that and followed your lead.
Well a man back in the 80s,
you could throw a fucking hot dogs.
The birds,
nobody would stop Ya.
Yeah.
He loves his car.
And there was no,
um,
there were no signs right there.
There's one sign around the entire two mile radius of that thing.
I know.
Fuck.
I felt like such an ass.
Well we didn't do it after that.
No,
my God,
no,
but no one did.
We were getting so many dirty looks we got.
Um,
I could not figure out why everyone hated us.
So much follow up video on somebody we featured a few weeks ago.
Oh,
no kidding.
Yeah.
What's that?
Do you mind already?
So can you sent a lot?
You do when you taste stuff a day.
I like that.
Ice Cream garbage.
It doesn't smell good centers acting as a passive sense for you.
Most of the time is a human being.
As a pup you're going to be using it as an active sense.
Activating those memories.
Act Associating again with your pop activities.
Street,
one width of your masters growing and you are beginning to snap into pup mode.
Boy.
Wow.
Because this was the pop guy.
We actually got bombarded with hatred for,
I think initially saying this guy was British New Zealand.
I know,
but that was a big fuck up and then I got yelled at and then we set Australian.
Oh No.
Corrected again.
The Kiwi's get very upset if you don't identify their accents and you being the
master.
Well I actually knew I was just,
you know,
I was seeing where can we do a perfect Kiwi accent?
Please go ahead.
Sure.
Hold on.
Underwear.
Are you a new best friend pub?
Your owner is going to make your pair of underwear.
Oh my God.
He's going to make sure that he leaves a bit of his center of his us going to
throw up
some smoothies piece at differently.
A few loads of calm.
Wow.
This got way better.
Could you repeat that in his accent?
Um,
underwear.
Are you a new best friend?
Underwear.
They're your new best friend.
I hear [inaudible] morning men,
Manchester.
Go ahead.
Your owner is going to make you a pair of underwear.
Your honor is going to make you a new pair of underwear go and what's going to
be allowed?
Underwear.
He's going to do a make sure that he leaves a bit of his center.
His ass,
his ass.
That's good.
Some smell of his piece and smell.
Definitely a few loads of calm.
Definitely a few loads.
Remember how the other video,
oddly enough,
that featured the pups.
They made it totally nonsexual.
Yeah,
that's the lie.
Right?
And we were like,
this is such a sexual young that they're,
they're minimizing.
Yeah.
Then you get them alone.
He's like,
I'm going to come all over this and you're going to smell it.
What a liar face.
I guess for the documentary,
they didn't want them to seem like total fetish derelicts,
but these guys are in their,
it's a community.
It's just,
it's freeing.
It's liberating.
They're coming all over each other and then he texts like dog outcome.
I'm going to come in my underwear and you're going to smell it.
It's such a big,
this is just called pup play.
Very normal.
Yeah.
Going to take a good,
strong smell of your own,
his underwear when you feel like it when you're pleasuring yourself.
I mean,
this guy is like a photo power dog.
He's a,
he's an aggressive top.
Yeah.
Importantly though,
is activities that you're going to be doing to help build up your set.
The first one in first collar training,
missy is to know your own smell.
Oh,
you know your smell when you wake up in the morning,
take a good with of your pit.
Yeah.
Before you've showered,
before you've put any deodorant,
Cologne.
Yeah.
No,
thanks.
So He's training us.
Yeah,
I got it.
Speaking of Dod collide and so it's time to change them.
Reduce your use of soap as much as you can.
Build what's necessary to keep yourself clean and sanitary as you like,
but get rid of perfumes,
soap as much as you can,
and drop deodorant down out of your use as much as possible.
There you go.
Nice and steak.
Lg sent.
Yeah.
When you've got time during your work day or during those moments when you're in
class,
you want to go here?
No.
Shoot your hand down your pants.
Grab your nuts.
Have a feel.
Get your fingers over them
and bring them up.
Yeah.
Was that just a show open?
Are those the Instagram teaser?
Did A,
Oh my God,
he's right.
I liked that.
He wears a tee shirt and leather pants.
Wolf.
The pup owner.
Trainer.
Yeah.
I want to watch that again.
I feel like my brain wasn't ready for that.
Oh yeah.
Sweet.
What'd you put time during those moments when you're in class,
when you've got a minute,
you want to go here?
Oh my lives.
Unlace your pants.
Unless your racket dots have a feel.
Please talk.
Get your fingers over them.
We'll bring them up.
Yeah.
Just unlace your patent leather pants in public and what kind of sent you think
he has going on down there?
Get strong.
Those pants are not bear out into soap.
We know that.
We know that his pants were not very poorest either.
If you're wearing patent leather,
and I know that from my golf days,
a lot of uh,
overweight golf girls will wear patent leather pants and,
and I hear it's not good.
Not good for your junk
smell.
Look at different times of the day in the morning when you wake up,
folded
going back.
Good photo of you nuts.
Yeah,
you should do that.
I can't take this.
I've done this so I can,
of course every guy in the world is doing,
but I've never done it in training.
I'm saying I do it straight without training their omics.
I need this guy to tell you how to grab your nuts and smell your fingers
after you've done that.
Reach further back.
Oh,
run your finger along your crack.
If you Ross,
you don't need to figure your whole,
you don't want to come back with shit on your finger.
Just run your finger over [inaudible] crack.
Oh God.
Bring it up and smell.
We've got to show us and my parents next.
See what they think of this.
So take your time out while you're at work and working with cubicles.
Cubicle your cubicle.
Do this.
Have the fondel have a quick sniff.
Yeah.
When you get home as you take off your ass,
can I get deep with,
have a very good deep Smith Smith.
The different parts of your underwear.
Learn what your ass smells like.
Coconut balls smell like.
I think you know,
but now you do.
You have to learn that smells like that now and make that a really keen sense of
yours.
Make it a priority as a pop.
Yeah,
we got it.
Schuman pop really connects with odor and sentence smell.
Yeah.
That's going to be a primal feeling for you.
Okay.
Oh,
that's Sirius pup.net is what I saw there.
They did exclude this from the documentary we saw on BBC.
They didn't really,
uh,
two.
It's the same way.
Yeah.
Do you really need a training course?
You know what?
Interestingly enough,
the very first time I ever saw Bert Kreischer,
he was,
we were living in the ghetto on your finger along your crack.
And he was pulled up in front of our apartment building and I had just happened
to be coming in from our garage and I looked out onto the street and I saw a guy
in a big SUV doing this.
Just smelling his hands.
Yes,
definitely doing what?
The master right trainer.
Right.
He was sniffing his fingers and I looked out and I go,
oh,
that's gotta be Bert Kreischer.
Yeah.
And then I went upstairs.
I was like,
I think Burt's out cry most his groin.
Yeah,
you did.
And I go,
yeah,
how did you know?
And you go,
there's a guy out there just stolen his fingers.
Yeah.
Just during the day,
if you've got a minute in between,
in between jobs.
Yeah.
If you're not talking to your boss,
unzip your leather pants,
Untie Hun,
lace them.
That lunatic had them laced up shoes.
We got to run a,
okay.
I love you.
This is the smells tracked by Dorian.
I don't,
I haven't heard it.
Um,
that you guys were listening.
Your mom's house,
podcast.com.
Hopefully next week I'll be back here with a beard and Gosh,
you will be at home.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
we appreciate you guys.
Hopefully we'll see many of you in Kansas City this weekend.
Anything else?
Jeans,
check out that Steve,
Bro,
checkout thousand ranch.com almost throw up and,
um,
I don't know.
Have a good week.
We love you and happy new year and that's it.
Do Good.
Be Good.
There you go.
Jeans.
Oh,
it's one of this man,
man,
nigger,
I really like
that
white nigger.
I really like that.
White niggers.
Yeah.